you guys uh it's such a big question to
ask
but superstore is ending
how do you feel where are you at
emotionally uh
how's it gonna be to watch this series
finale
i'm broken i am broken
oh no it's hard it's just really you
know it's it's it's been six years of
our lives we've gone so
uh grown so close and and you know we
you know we keep saying this at every
interview but
we really are we're we're a family so
just sort of
um you know the last day of work was
very hard
and and and going in for our final like
adrs and then the last sort of like
business that we had to tie up with the
show was also hard but now that we are
approaching
the the airing of the finale like
i don't know i'm i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be all sorts of messica alba girl it's
gonna be
yeah okay so we'll go out to dinner
because
i want to not you me exactly and you
probably want to go somewhere fancy like
tony rotundo's because that's how
pathetic you are oh
i felt like i was seeing some real tears
in your eyes and i don't know if i'm
projecting that on you but
oh you're not projecting uh i haven't
seen the finale yet so i don't know
which
scene you're referring to but i don't
need to know because i cried through the
whole thing
um i mean when we in the table read for
the episode
uh the scene the final scene between
dina and glenn
i couldn't get through reading that
scene on the zoom table read
and shooting it that day and you know
turning to mark and i i mean i can't
even talk about it now like it's
it's it's immensely emotional you know
and
uh it's uh i don't think i've even begun
to
even begun processing really what that
that loss is because you know i keep
saying to people you know it is it is a
loss to grieve
so like nico i think it's not gonna be
until after i watch that final episode
that then it'll be like okay
now the work begins now the healing
begins you know let's
let's do that and colton you you have to
give that final announcement
yeah yes what was that like
uh well you know i mean the well the
nice part on
on sort of the job end of it is that we
you know this last these last two
episodes
we shot you know over a two week period
uh
long long hours so by the time i was
shooting that scene
um you know i wasn't you know it was
very very much work
but you were exhausted i was tired
uh but you know what i but i also really
love the scene
uh you know i love what uh you know what
garrett was saying there
and uh you know obviously it's clear on
the page you know how important
uh it uh it resonates uh you know with
everything that's gone in for not just
the characters
but the series to the fans but also even
to us as
actors um you know those words are all
words that are coming out i think all of
our mouths
um in some form or another um so
i was just honored to be able to have
that that part um and to be able to book
in that performance of garrett
where he really brings us into the world
of superstore and he really takes us out
of it
nicole just told me that you were all
played this surprise montage that had
been made
um where i can't imagine the tears
weren't flowing in that she said you
didn't know it was coming you thought it
was a glitch and then all of a sudden
you're watching this montage of bloopers
and great moments from
the whole six years you spent doing this
for six seasons
yeah it's great you know we were
shooting the scene uh that in the um
finale episode is when we are watching
the videos of our old uh
interviews uh and so that's the actual
final you know for the fun factors out
there that's the final scene that we
shot so when we finished shooting that
scene
they yelled cut and we were done uh with
uh performing those characters so
uh it was also a perfect situation for
them to play uh kind of this uh you know
very
uh heart uh touching tape i guess you
could say
yeah just seeing seeing all those i mean
like you you forget some of those
moments because
you know 113 episodes like so many
things have happened and they all kind
of just
melt together in your brain but like it
was nice sort of like going back and and
and sort of like seeing and remembering
like um all these like crazy moments
that happened between
between takes did you guys steal
anything from set
confessions are welcome any mementos or
so many things you did so many things
yeah well i've been taking stuff from
set since season
two this is from season two
but final episode i i did we be pillaged
so
i love that yeah i would just like to
say that you you're not supposed to take
any props uh from any universal set
uh and you can be punished
okay and i don't see any props here
today no no no no no i don't see any
props
i don't see anything we went crazy that
last night like it got
nuts like it was just like what can we
have like and i think also like we were
like at the end of day 12 of 12 we
didn't have any days off in the middle
like it was just like
like literally like me going up to like
art department and being like what do
you got for me
like give me something you know um so
yeah i gotta i got a bunch of stuff too
good well i have to rap with you guys
but um very quickly if anybody wants to
weigh in of course
america came back this season um what
was it like for you guys to be able to
have her on set again and to all be
together
you know there's absolutely no way that
we could have closed out this show
without her that would have just been
ridiculous so i mean definitely it's a
little weird
usually you don't have somebody who
leaves a show
after the second episode that comes back
and everybody acts like they've been
gone for a very long time but
you know there's no way there's no way
to end this one without having her there
so i'm so thankful that she was able to
do it
and we know that the fans want a
spin-off can we see you guys on another
project another superstar series
who knows i mean they are developing bo
and cheyenne
so i'm sure you know matteo and cheyenne
have been longtime partners in crime so
you know um if they ask mateo to to make
a guest appearance i will certainly
gladly
uh savored a chance of of being being
dumb
with cheyenne again listen from the very
beginning of this show i said
superstore's gonna get picked up and
it's gonna run for seven seasons we ran
for six which makes me believe there is
a reboot season that is gonna happen at
some time
you know who knows when but i know that
i'm not wrong and i don't want to admit
that i've been wrong
so i think this isn't the end of
superstore
in my mind you know